[Musique]
pour bruno retailleau bonjour elizabeth
martichoux et merci d'être ce matin sur
lci alors que démarre à l'instant même
je pense au sénat votre maison
l'audition par la délégation
parlementaire de christophe castaner
suivront deux autres rendez-vous pour
d'ailleurs le ministre de l'intérieur
cet après midi à l'assemblée est à
nouveau au sénat avec la commission des
lois jeudi qu'elle est la première
question que vous lui poseriez si vous
étiez ce matin en face de lui pour leur
entrevue
écoutez je lui dirai monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur cet attentat
aurait pu contrairement aux autres sans
doute il aurait pu être évité il est
très grave parce que c'est un terroriste
qui a agi au sein d'un service anti
terroriste
il ya eu non pas des dysfonctionnements
mais des failles pensez vous que des
enquêtes administratives puissent
suffire pour traiter ce problème pensez
vous que il puisse y avoir une
responsabilité de lampiste simplement je
me souviens que pour les deux femmes
assassinées à marseille gare saint
charles
un préfet avait été d'ailleurs
injustement limogé monsieur le premier
ministre
sommes nous monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur il n'est pas encore premier
ministre
heureusement pouvez-nous nous dire si
vous pouvez vous satisfaire de ce que
demain des lampistes pourrait payer vous
dit prenez vos responsabilités si
j'entends bien monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est-à-dire qui ne fait pas
payer en piste vous même posez vous des
questions sur votre maintien bien sûr
c'est ça vous dit rien sur des missions
vous dit
franchement cette routine que les
oppositions on a demandé
systématiquement des démissions un
moment ou un autre ça affaiblit le
message moi je pense que ça le concerne
lui comme responsables publics
je pense que ça concerne surtout le
président de la république christophe
castaner est à sa place parce que le
président république l'a bien voulu
il avait d'ailleurs mis quinze jours à
le nommer il aurait dû peut-être
attendre encore un peu oui donc c'est
très clair vous lui dites prenez vos
responsabilités si j'étais à votre place
peut-être un peu facile d'ailleurs parce
que tout ministre de l'intérieur dans
cette situation bruno retailleau
seraient fragilisés comme il l'est et
est ce que lui et même les services de
l'état peuvent surveiller tout tous les
individus ou les individus susceptibles
d oui dans un service dans un service
stratégique dans un service qui a pour
mission la recherche du renseignement
pour la lutte anti rides antiterroriste
contre l'islamisme radical
bien sûr d'autant plus que contrairement
à ce que christophe castaner a trop
rapidement indiqué le terroriste avait
fait l'objet d' alerte sérieuse puisque
il avait déclaré après l'attentât de
charlie hebdo que c'était bien fait
c'est passible en réalité d'une sanction
c'est un délit l'apologie du terrorisme
donc je dis que oui
cet attentat aurait pu être évité mais
park ses conséquences il est
particulièrement grave nous savons
désormais que sur une clé usb se
trouvaient des dizaines et des dizaines
d'adressent de policiers peut-être même
d'ailleurs cet individu avait t-il accès
à des informations qui concernait la
lutte antiterroriste par exemple des
personnes des terroristes potentiels
visite non c'est très grave parce que
c'est la sûreté c'est la sécurité de
l'état je suis étonné d'ailleurs très
franchement que mails macron est
attendue pratiquement une semaine il va
s'exprimer bien sûr j'y serai dans
quelques heures dans la cour de la
préfecture de police
attendre attendre dans cours de
l'hommage bien sûr mes attentes pour une
affaire qui est une affaire qui touche
vraiment à la sécurité de l'état
je pense que tous les français attendent
son expression lui qui d'habitude quoi
cela aurait il était utile bruno
retailleau
emmanuel macron se précipitent pour
s'adresser aux français je ne lui
demande pas de se précipiter
je pense que la faute de christophe
castaner cet été de céder justement à
cette communication qui va trop vite et
qui vous attache au piquet de l'instant
mais entre faire ce que fait monsieur
castaner se précipiter et attendre une
semaine très franchement il ya une
mesure d'autant plus que en général les
mails macro n'est pas avare de sa parole
il intervient partout il s'exprime sur
tout sauf
oui sauf sur un point capital sauf sur
un point
j'écoutais je vous lisiez pardon vous
êtes pouvait être convaincu de
contradictions vous disiez il n'a pas
parlé de rouen sur rouen la semaine
dernière après évidemment l'explosion un
dramatique de lubrizol
il devrait parler il n'est pas partout
et serait-il partout peut-être que vous
lui reproche laurier d'être avant lui
demande de sauter comme un marsupilami
surtout les faits dans les grandes
catastrophes
je suis désolé dans les gratte moi j'ai
vécu de catastrophe notamment la
dernière en vendait c'était il ya dix
ans pratiquement ses xynthia 29 morts je
me souviens du déplacement de nicolas
sarkozy
et ce sont des déplacements certes qui
sont symboliques n'y a pas besoin de
faire de grands discours mais ça
témoigne pour les victimes pour leur
famille du soin que prend l'état pour
voir et je pense que là encore c'est le
coeur du coeur de l'état le poison
islamistes c'est donc infiltré dans
l'appareil d'état
petite parenthèse d'ailleurs une
question qui pas encore tellement apparu
mais je vous la pose ce matin par
rapport à ce poison djihadistes une
formule qu'a pris françois fillon
d'ailleurs hier dans un tweet s'est
exprimée exceptionnellement est ce qu'il
ne faudrait pas que les les porte-voix
du monde musulman réagissent davantage
puisque pour lutter contre la propagande
ce qu'il faut est ce que vous souhaitez
qu'il le fasse et pourquoi ne font-ils
pas à votre avis en france quand il ya
un événement aussi dramatique
j'ai vu une déclaration du cfcm donc on
ne peut pas dire qu'ils ne font pas du
tout simplement je considère que il ya
deux voies ceux qui veulent qu'ils
veulent organiser l'islam de france
en touchant à la loi de 1905 ça a été à
l'origine une des intentions des mails
mâcon je pense qu'il y a et j'espère
renoncer
je pense que c'est pas à la république
de s'adapter à l'islam celle inverse et
aux religions de s'adapter à un public
et je pense que la question c'est dans
l'islam qu'elle se pose c'est dans
l'islam je confonds pas je sais très
bien que tous les musulmans sont pas des
islamistes mais tous les islamistes
pratiquer une forme d'islam radical je
pense que les grandes voix de l'islam
kenyan la transitique malek chebel malek
feu malek chebel a dit un jour ouais
c'est terrible l'islam de nos grands
parents a perdu eh bien non c'est islam
là ne doit pas perdre
faut-il aller bruno retailleau revenons
aux solutions en réponse qui sont
attendus après cet attentat
jusqu à révoquer les fonctionnaires qui
se radicalise oui bien sûr il faut les
écarter
assurément tout radicaliser est un
potentiel oui oui oui bien sûr dessus
tout un radical is est peut-être dans
les services publics dont vériste aux
religieux j'écoutais je vais essayer de
me faire comprendre j'écoutais ce matin
un chroniqueur dans une matinale qui
indiquait que le président de république
avait commandé à son entourage
un discours qui va prononcer à la
préfecture de police
discours d'hommage sur la tonalité d'un
discours de clemenceau en 1917
quel est ce discours de clémence aux
vendeurs de 1917
aujourd hui la matériel je fais la
guerre à l'extérieur je fais la guerre à
l'intérieur je fais la guerre nous
faisons la guerre contre le terrorisme
islamiste à l'extérieur au sahel
il ya eu 29 soldats français morts
fêtons la guerre évidemment avec
d'autres moyens que l'armée mais fait-on
la guerre sur le plan taille non je
pense qu'on n'a pas pris toute la mesure
où le curseur à bruno retailleau
mais quelques jours à quel moment décide
qu'un individu fonctionnaires de l'état
et suffisamment radicaliser pour que
effectivement ils soient les chaussons
presse la fonction publique quand un
fonctionnaire notamment à fonctionnaires
qui agit dans un cadre de la sécurité de
l'état fait l'apologie du terrorisme
on ne se pose pas de questions quand un
fonctionnaire pratiquent un islam
salafiste se rend dans une moc et
mosquées a des contacts réguliers avec
des imams
qui sont d'obédience frère aux
salafistes ce sont des indices et ces
indices je pense qu'il faut être
implacables
parce qu'on doit se défendre on doit
faire cette guerre sur notre territoire
avec les moyens de droit qui sont les
nôtres bien évidemment nous sommes un
état de droit mais justement pour que
nous soyons un état de droit il faut que
la loi républicaine soit au dessus de la
charia ce que vous avez vu ce chiffre
qui était donné par fourquet jérôme
fourquet juste après d'ailleurs deux ans
après l'étude ainsi tu mens tu ailles 27
% de nos compatriotes musulmans place la
charia au dessus de la loi la république
c'est terrifiant donc il ya si j'ose
dire un double phénomène le djihadisme
qui nous paralyse qui nous tétanise par
sa violence et il ya une forme d' anna
lisa sion d'islamisation sur des
territoires de la république qui est la
fabrique de ces djihadistes et il faut
lutter contre l'un est contre l'autre
par exemple sur la burqa
moi je propose que l'on passe d'un
système de contraventions un système de
délits et je pense que pour les
multirécidivistes
on doit les privés dette sociale et
faire que je pense qu'on doit marquer la
pesée cas les femmes qui portent la
burqa dans les banlieues est
effectivement en oui notamment de
l'ile-de-france absolue elles sont
passibles de dénis et pas seulement d'un
match avec déjà la maman pas appliquer
son passif absolument c'est pour ça que
je propose d'en faire un délit je
propose aussi lorsqu il y a récidive
devait passer de passe de supprimer les
aides sociales
supprimez aides sociales passibles de
prison une femme en burqa pour 1 m en
tout cas en tout cas ça doit être un
délit
on ne doit être implacable exactement je
propose par ailleurs qu'on mobilise la
législation contre les sectes parce que
je pense que le salafisme a quelque
chose à voir notamment lorsqu'il
influence des esprits faibles
on a une législation qui est très forte
alors viens vous faire sursauter
je vais vous faire sursauter ça va
jusqu'à trois ans de de prison ça va
jusqu'à 375 mille euros d'amendé
mais si on ne fait pas ça et bien
d'autres choses aussi nous perdrons
cette bataille donc moi je veux pas la
peur pour mes enfants
accor donc vous condamner ce courant de
pensée un l'islam dans certains disent
qu'il n'est pas forcément d'ailleurs
porté sur la violence
le condamnez vous fermez les masques et
ça je ferme et mosquée depuis 2010 est
depuis 2010 à dire depuis l'adoption de
la loi sur le terrorisme n'y a eu que
quinze mosquées qui ont été fermés on
sait qu'il y à peu près 200 mosquées
salafistes je propose qu'on change la
loi parce que quand on a quitté l'état
d'urgence
on s'est un peu affaibli en matière de
fermetures de mosquées je pense qu'il
faut ré aussi là aussi cette exigence
oui ou non
voulons-nous lutter contre ce phénomène
ils nous font la guerre
est ce que le gouvernement seront selon
vous oui ou non vote il luttait qu'il ya
une énorme ambiguïté il faut qu'ils
mêlent macro et y répondre et s'il ya
une annuelle mater concernant la
question de la laïcité
ça fait bientôt trois ans vous savez
contactant le grand discours sur la
laïcité moi je l'attends toujours
il hésite je la perds qui ne changera
pas qui la touchera pas un discours
devant les bernardin mais ce n'était pas
un discours sur la laïcité pas du tout
au contraire d'ailleurs je pense c'est
une fausse conception qu'il exprime est
ambiguë bien sûr il est temps bill il
est ambigu il était comme candidat je me
souviens il avait eu vous souvenez un
référent un march qui étaient convaincus
d'une forme de racket radicalisation il
avait dit c'est quelqu'un de bien
bon il l'a fait après je me souviens du
discours de marseille il arrive un de
ces grands meetings s'adresse aux
français en disant je vois des algériens
des marocains nous non quelles que
soient leurs origines des français sont
des citoyens français est est ce que
toutes les mesures que vous proposez là
est ce que christophe castaner est
l'homme de la situation
moi je pense que non non je pense que
non parce que c'est un récidiviste il ya
quelques mois pendant l'histoire des
gilets jaunes
il ya déjà eu un dérapage il avait
accusé
vous avez des gilet jaune d'avoir
attaqué un hôpital la pitié salpêtrière
voilà à rouen l'argent vite
il a c'est pour ça il a récidivé il
parle trop vite je pense que l'autorité
de l'état
pour un ministre de l'intérieur c'est
d'abord la maîtrise de sa propre parole
pourquoi est il maintenu pourquoi ils
doivent filippetti mars qu'il ait envie
est très proche des mâles macron kemmel
macron veut avoir un ministre comme de
nuit sans doute sans doute mais mais le
tout le problème c'est que tout ça
revient de toute façon dans la
république m'a crânienne actuelle vers
jupiter
c'est jupiter qui commande donc c'est
pour ça que je demande pas la démission
de monsieur castaner j'attends du
président république un discours de
fermeté
mais j'attends qu'il dépasse les mots
mêmes les débats comme celui qui a eu
lieu hier à l'assemblée sur les mix sert
à rien j'entends in sert à rien
le président de la république prenne
avec courage des mesures contre on parle
rap si vous voulez l'immigration mais
contre la radicalisation elisabeth
badinter a eu justement raison
lorsqu'elle dit que une seconde société
tente de s'imposer dans la république
avec des visées séparatistes voir
sécessionnistes et l'a parfaitement
raison c'est si on ne prend pas je vous
savez finalement les lois l'arsenal
juridique policiers on l'a plus ou moins
on là je propose des ajustements mais ce
qui manque c'est le courage ce qui
manque c'est de prendre la mesure des
choses ce qui manque je discutais avec
une de mes sénatrice elle a été maire
d'une commune pas très loin d'ici
de 20000 habitants et me disaient mais
on a capitulé et me dit un jour je fais
une une exposition il y avait eu une
femme de dos son dos est ténue et bien
l'inspectrice de l'éducation nationale
lui a demandé de couvrir cette photo qui
pouvaient choquer des envies vous rendez
compte
au point où on en est on est en train de
capituler si on est dans le déni ville à
sion dénis ambiguïté à propos d'
immigration vous en parliez à l'instant
débat à l'assemblée nationale débat au
sénat jeudi vous serez premier
inventaire d'ailleurs faire croire mais
mercredi pardon demain pardon demain
après l'expression des premiers
ministres pourquoi est ce qu'il a voulu
ce débat votre avis le président parce
qu'il ya tout juste un an la loi agit d'
immigration a été promulguée c'est très
court à une loi et c'était au mois de
septembre donc un an et au bout d'un an
on a constaté l'échec
il a constaté son propre échec mails
mâcon puisque et ça a échappé à beaucoup
d'observateurs et devant les
ambassadeurs dabo devant les
ambassadeurs devant la conférence des
ambassadeurs ça ne ment il a dit voilà
on est devenue le premier pays européen
2 rebonds pour les déboutés du droit
mais beaucoup parlé on a fait beaucoup
débat là dessus sur lci bon c'est bien
il il a constaté l'échec et il veut le
réparer et d'ailleurs hier agnès buzyn
l'assemblée a défendu le principe de
l'aide médicale d'état tout en
souhaitant une petite réforme on écoute
et on se retrouve après voulons éviter
que des personnes utilisent le vecteur
de la demande d'asile dans le seul but
d'obtenir la prise en charge de soins
qui peuvent être réalisées dans leur
pays un délai de carence pendant lequel
nous prendrions évidemment en charge les
soins urgents pourrait se concevoir ce
délai de carence de trois mois existe
d'ailleurs déjà pour les français qui
rentrent de l'étranger sans activité
professionnelle
les allocations et meurent est également
si ému qui sont respectivement accordée
aux clandestins pour le premier aux
demandeurs d'asile pour le second il y
aura des critères plus restrictifs bonne
réponse bravo madame busin la ministre
de la santé
mais je l'attends au pied du mur puisque
chaque année le sénat dans cadre du
projet de loi de finances nous proposons
une transformation non pas la
suppression de m
nous proposons de la transformer en aide
médicale d'urgence avec un panier de
soins qu'ils soient reçus chaque année
le gouvernement elle a dit à l'aise non
les luttes et combien les abus oui ou
non ça ne va pas les mots ne me font pas
parce que la politique de ce
gouvernement et des maquereaux
c'est de faire semblant c'est de faire
semblant c'est de fonds sableux faire
ensemble faire mais je jugerai l'arbre à
ses fruits
simplement comment vous expliquez pour
les afghans par exemple que le taux de
protection en france et 83%
donc ils obtiennent l'asile très
facilement en allemagne c'est 3% il ya
une singularité française dans que
didier leschi explique très bien dans un
ouvrage publié à fondapol il ya un an
j'ai été sans doute le seul à lire à
l'époque qui dit tout il y tout encore
un petit mot bruno retailleau et thouars
filippi hier devant l'assemblée a évoqué
la théorie du grand emplacement le grand
remplacement c'est du complotisme at il
dit et ça ni pas à la main
sûrs d'eux l'idée qu'on se fait de la
france pour vous cette théorie du grand
emplacement c'est du complotisme c'est
une réalité et même une menace plutôt
une menace et même une réalité non ça
fait partie des expressions qui vise à
transformer la figure de l'immigré un
bouc émissaire gers à chine je pense que
si on ne veut pas encourager ce type de
complotisme il faut traiter les choses
de façon démocratique c'est pour ça que
je suis pour le vote
chaque année au parlement de plafond
d'immigration marcel gauchet l'a très
bien dit vous savez et cottin
l'immigration et cote à l'immigration de
masse par métier l'immigration de masse
l'immigration de masse est sans doute le
phénomène qui a le plus profondément
bouleversé nos sociétés or on a tenu le
peuple
la délibération démocratique à l'écart
de ce phénomène de transformation et là
où je rejoins emmanuel macron lorsqu'il
dit à deux conceptions finalement ce duo
qui ont les moyens de se protéger des
effets les effets des migrations par des
stratégies d'évitement résidentiel
d'évitement scolaire et il ya le peuple
qui n'a pas les moyens le compte de se
constituer pendant bien sûr il est bon
bien sûr il est bon un petit mot j'adore
plus constat j'attends encore une fois
des actes et j'en ai pas vu le meilleur
agent n'est pas juste avant qu'on se
quitte
vous avez un point commun et xavier
bertrand dit notre ancien collègue de l
est aujourd'hui président d autres ans
et un ami alors si vous y pensez aussi
il y pense il ya encore plus que moi non
non je sais pas je l'écouté ils portent
beaucoup et vous on vous a écouté vous
avez dit aussi j'y pense je réfléchis
j'ai simplement indiqué que si mes
convictions sont portés je me rallierai
vers celle ou celui qui les portera si
elles ne le sont pas portés je
m'interrogerais sérieusement oui alors
vous ne pensez pas depuis tout petit ou
tous les matin en vous rasant c'est quoi
votre détermination après tout quand on
combine accéder sont tous deux accédé au
siège suprême un publique française il
faut a quand même un degré de
détermination le c'est exceptionnel quel
est le vôtre
eh bien je pense que l'envi ne peut pas
être une détermination la vraie
détermination politique parce que c'est
l'honneur de la politique ce sont les
convictions ou mes convictions parce que
je je sens les moyens qui permettra à la
france de se relever
parce que c'est un pays qui a énormément
d'atouts
je pense qu'elle m'a qu'on n'aura pas du
tout de résultats parce qu'encore une
fois il semble faire mais il fait
semblant et je crois que de ce point de
vue là ou bien ces idées seront portées
ce projet sera porté puis je le porterai
qu'est ce que vous voulez je vous dise
eh ben dis donc l enthousiasme
on verra dans les mois qui viennent
merci beaucoup bruno retailleau de
mercier ce matin